Shawn how are you this morning I'm doing
well how about yourself I'm doing okay
what's up what is the population of
Parsons Kansas
oh it's between Pryor 10 and 12,000 most
famous person in Parsons is probably the
most famous person ever be bill gas bill
Guthrie North Carolina head coach yes
sir oh well but where are you on that
list Oh make the top ten I don't know
all right how do I introduce you
starting quarterback for the Vikings you
know I have no idea just uh just Sean
he'll be fine but do you know if your
who's starting Sunday night is that
decision been made not to my knowledge
it has not but you know I approach every
week exact same you know so either way
I'm gonna prepare the same how would you
grade your performance week one in the
win over the Titans well you know
obviously there's there some things
there's a few plays I'd like to have
back and a couple plays that could have
been made that weren't we would have
liked to have scored more touchdowns we
put together some good drives but but
ended and field goals so what I like to
had more touchdowns in those drives but
you know the most important things we've
got out of there with a win
Teddy Bridgewater did you contact him he
contact you before the game he contacted
me yeah he reached out and I was very
supportive and and you know just just
told me to uh to remember to go out and
have fun
and you know he's he's such a great guy
was it was good to hear from him for the
game what was your feeling reaction when
you when you understood the severity of
his injury on that that day in practice
well I don't think that there is anybody
that saw it that that didn't understand
exactly what had happened you know it
was it was tough to watch tough to see
and tough to see your guy go down like
that
so you know it was it was shocking for
everybody involved and
you know but it was it was really nice
to see him when he got back into the end
of the building see him smiling uh you
know and just just you knew you got a
sense from him that you know what he's
gonna he's gonna come back from this
he's gonna he's gonna be better for he's
Shaun Hill the Vikings quarterback they
have the Packers Sunday night on NBC
joining a Stan Patrick show every
quarterback has pride and but you have
to know your place where where you are
as a starting quarterback or as a backup
quarterback how do you sort of get to
that point where you say okay this is
who I am is this tuck as a quarterback
in the NFL we're having have you gotten
to that point well I think the most
important thing is just to always put
the team first and and I've always done
that any kind of personal accolades that
have come about have been because we had
a good team you know whether that's in
high school or college or or in the pros
it it really you know as long as you put
the team first and what's best for the
team then then I think that that really
helps especially in situations like this
you know that I've played a long time
and I'll tell you what the only thing I
really want is a Super Bowl ring and and
whoever's going to whoever's gonna bring
that or help this team get that then I'm
all for what's changed since you came in
in 2002 to now on the field at the
quarterbacking position well it has
evolved a little bit you see a lot of
teams kind of going a lot more up-tempo
you see some some zone read stuff
quarterbacks carrying the football so it
has changed a little bit but you know
there's there's still a lot of systems
though that are that are just the way
they've been for twenty thirty years you
know some of the same pass concepts that
work 20-30 years ago are still working
today so they're still still a lot of
that going on for sure how many jerseys
do you have frame gosh I don't know I
honestly don't know but all your stops
did you keep your jerseys yeah
have-have from all my stops all the all
the home jerseys our friend yeah how
many well it would be Minnesota the
first time no let's let's start with
Amsterdam Amsterdam Admirals a Minnesota
ace San Francisco and then there's
there's a throwback San Francisco in
there Detroit and a throwback Detroit
one there's a st. Louis and then now
there's another another Minnesota one
now you're famous or infamous because of
the Calvin Johnson rule right you you
shoot you through the what should have
been a touchdown pass that was called
incomplete yeah yeah and I'm glad you
agree that it should have been a
touchdown well that whole thing is silly
I think Calvin got up and was ready to
celebrate and I do know what a catch he
is Sean yeah yeah that look like it gets
to me
what about nailed oh gosh I honestly I
don't you know you need to tell the guys
to uh come up with a ball you know hand
the ball to the official after every
play and then and that takes all that
out of it and I wonder if that's what
they're going to say from now on you
just have to hand the ball to the
official for that to be an official
catch because then that would rule out
that would wipe out any of this other
gray area stuff but I mean the Calvin
Johnson thing started I mean it's
steamrolled after that but now that
became silly yeah yeah it is it's it's
crazy but yeah hopefully hopefully at
some point we can get some clarity on
that well hopefully your clarity on
who's the starting quarterback against
the Packers here Sean we appreciate your
time Congrats on the win in Tennessee
alright thank you very much
it says Sean Hill he's the pride of
Parsons Kansas but not the most famous
person out of Parsons Kansas the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience